une vraie stratégie de moralisation de
la vie
plus député la république en marge des
hauts-de-seine série solaire également
conseillé d' emmanuel macron a été mise
en examen pour cinq nouvelles
infractions les juges le soupçonne
d'avoir utilisé une partie de ses frais
de mandat pour régler des amendes des
frais courants des abonnements cela
entre 2012 et 2019 en tout ça fait 12
faits pour lesquels il est mis en examen
une vraie stratégie de moralisation de
la vie publique cendres benalla filmé en
train de s'en prendre violemment à deux
personnes en marge des manifestations du
1er mai
l'homme est un proche conseiller
d'emmanuel macron en charge de la
sécurité du président alexandre au pénal
à disposer d'un appartement dans une
dépendance de l'elysée d'une voiture de
fonction équipés de dispositifs réservés
à la police mais aussi d'un badge lui
permettant d'accéder librement à
l'hémicycle
une vraie stratégie de moralisation de
la vie publique si kohler est soupçonné
d'avoir caché à bercy ses liens
familiaux avec la famille à ponte à la
tête de la société msc le premier
pourvoyeur de commandes des chantiers de
saint nazaire une enquête est ouverte au
parquet national financiers pour prise
illégale d'intérêt le 1er juillet 2019
une lettre est versée au dossier acron
est il directement intervenu dans une
procédure judiciaire pour aider son bras
droit alexis kohler le secrétaire
général de l'elysée son ancien directeur
de cabinet à bercy
une vraie stratégie de moralisation de
la vie publique